chiunque ragazzi non posso farmi vedere
che cos'è questa roba per che uscirà nei
blog più avanti
[Musica]
volevo dirvi che stiamo su benedetto e
con sasha che
sapremo se una intro di un video
registrato è anni fa non ti preoccupare
perché video vi piace server anima
password anima non entreranno mai
esatto io la prima cosa che scrivo il
nome del server quando gioco cerco di a
schierare per virtus
quindi per me entrare anche il mio
canale e fa vigenti vola passo c'è la
luna va bene ma lo so partiamo subito
con una strana buono di uno stigma no
calma con lo spinge attiva niente uno
che siamo in coppia o andremo lineare 10
e riesce a pescare anche a fare un salto
mi sento un mongolo
credo che sia la solita io vado di
parole deve essere by uomo quante sala
testa aranci l'arancina 5 non in questo
modo lancia la già occhio greci ma
allora spiega mia tv che prima di
lanciare a lanciare una destra e colpo
della tastiera e va bene c'è una luna
enorme che gira in mezzo sta che dovrà
non l'ho capito che cosa brutta mai
lanciati occhio zebra fascia ora tocca a
me l'aspettavo fabio corner ceppo i
ricchi schiacciare un pulsante miss a
qualche parte non so dove effettivamente
devi andare ma non è il pulsante quale
sarebbe e mi sa che deve venire quassù
e allora forse diventeranno c'è una
ciminiera lì davanti vedi vai vai mai
grazie ai sei parà della prima o dopo
con l'acqua rischia cervo dopo cosa devo
della mi piace la schiaccia lo è grazie
vai vai non ci arriva ma devo che parla
di citare annamaria per voi ma come no
non direi suicidare potevi stare là
sopra è difficile sta parte vai mai
verrai madonna quorum che l'asino c'è
casino io fra il proseguo così perché a
baila york ora io sto anche una
novantina bisogno io devo devo
schiacciarti perché mai lasciato
qualcosa addosso ti dovrebbero un
pulsante secondo me siamo maestro
no si premino ri premio ho premuto non
ci arrivavo porca aspettate schiacceremo
bye bye al che ho capito cosa di fare
valori primo sì fi perfetto e la santa
sull'altro madonna che casino l'altro
quale l'altro lasciano un altro avanti
ok macello madonna che casino vice asha
grazie se il mio nuovo ascensore oggi
perfetto lascio massiccio e adesso sono
pulsanti a schiacciare ho mai dico sì ok
premi cosa premo allora fermo hai detto
tu di schiacciarlo
[Risate]
che tempismo e che abbiamo nel prenderci
per il culo
ok ci sono perfetto fa in fretta di
visto si dice qualcosa noi difficile non
ancora non ancora lanci cava che sfiga
di me ma la leva tutto vuole fatto sì
l'ho fatto io per sbaglio hai a sasha
veloce ma oggi è impossibile non ci
arriva la testa mi sa che devo salire
ancora
ok i primi quello che porta su solo
propria porta su barca va anche sono
l'arte aspetta se vi si lascia la mamma
mia donna schiacciatore mara jungle la
mozzarella con la buna specie quello
quello dopo schiaccia un piccolo vicolo
vicino alla destra
vai adesso se adesso che non ce l'avevo
visto che è perfetto
perciò io sono solo per esempio le
salutami ciao
ok adesso che si prepara che saluto da
mongolo cha cha
come ha fatto arrivare link caso bisogna
chat ciao signora perfetto stai fermo lì
mantovana alle progetto ora che è
difficilissimo e difficilissimo devono
essere veramente kobe bryant cioè che
ben barka che richiama di nuovo lo
stress
no l'ho già fatta oddio da un chilometro
pre sono
questo fenomeno sata ii ok adesso li se
sei fermatisi attivo per l'altro
ok l'altro quale questo no è così tesoro
madonna che sudata della morte ma tu
come ci si poteva farci arrivare te l'ho
fatta io ce l'ho fatta oddio come stai
correndo gli occhi lancio la mia testa
in testa è stato sono sharepoint di
sempre ok bravo a queste cristiano
ronaldo c 6 europea anzi roberto carlos
mio era esatto ma qualcosa mai e tu sei
la palla e domani gli olo ma dalla parte
sbagliata 8 il fuoco aspetta ora che
siamo tutti in fila in fila indiana ai
quali non hanno spinto ai a fuoco ma ci
hai fatta io non ci credo ho chiamato
tutto a riesca a gli stylist e li lascia
occhio a chi oggi occhio facciate
facendo però ma cosa che è successo
simile contratto e 28 su 15 che sudore
su 15 o mio dio c per 30 secondi c'era
che non ci posso credere statali grosso
sto sudando te lo giuro
adesso si deve fare in dieci minuti ma
perché c'é la musica di adel sotto è
vero ma è messo il sound dei poteri
dicendo un caso va dai dieci minuti st 9
possibile anche 200 ce l'ho fatta ma
come sarà c'è fuori non mi chiede come
mai fatta quasi bravo bravo bravo
ok se bene siamo arriva a occhio occhio
di ice tea no no no no no cosa non ci
fosse crederci hai fatto normale vai vai
zio vai mo chi cup è che so quanti gli
olo lo dice poi alla fine motivi cesto
livello cioè fatta giovanna non ci posso
credere brava hai fatto questo perché
era più difficile in un secondo le
nostre gravi difetti fice questo la
costamagna centrale è ma ci ho provato
prima ma non c'è niente aver spetta ok
ok scialla scialla c 6 c 6 c sarà addio
o mano armata mai mai su su su su
rivelarci ma anche molto ritirarci
scattare cosa dobbiamo avere qui
eleonora scuri non riescono a come tu
impossibile e la si può fare fatto bravo
sempre concentrato e quali nuovo c'è da
fare una roba di prima non cadere non
cadere non cadere non abbiamo più tempo
per rifarci a seccare abbiamo perso
prima intenzione di sto mettendo questi
ok o mio dio
ok devi arrivare al check point qui che
bello
scusami non pensavo fosse così letale
non prendiamoci il tempo manca poco la
cia il colle cioè gol sasha ott la luna
tre minuti abbiamo lascia il calcio
guarda in fondi dove partiti salto dove
siamo tutti i salti tutti fatti fino
alla fine è tutto un salto salivano ti
schianti solo pendibene è esatto per
quello che ti dicevo prima che attento
che ti stai schiantando dai sasha due
minuti ma anche ora ce la possiamo fare
in due minuti e minimo sbaglio muori ce
ne sono tantissimi ok ci sono arrivato
ci sono arrivato di gol per iron verso
ok ma che ha dati faceva spettatori un
minuto e 39 cazzo dei saf hai la pancia
fai dai sensi dove non ti dà una mano
come spettatore dai bravo bravo così non
me lo faccio con la fiat
no un minuto sasha cori corri corri
sasha cori corre il minuto e bye bye bye
bye sugli esterni esterni vai da schifo
cha cha cha cha
cosa è successo sasha 118 e non c'è
gioco più vento victory lorca dal 50
vita e 49 response mai vinto perché
veniva chiave inglese è la chiave
inglese che porta fortuna centro da fare
e con una gran parte di tokyo alle
spalle un signore che sta cercando di
infiltrarsi nel mio video io spero che
vi sia piaciuto come il momento mi piace
anche come descrizione tu dovresti
chiedere che ci vediamo
hanno capito non c'è signore della
faglia tesi
[Musica]